okay hi to people joining us we are
looking at some designs related to trees
oh i should have looked at this agenda
before this is the old version where
there are lots of examples but
no no no don't close it it's my
um
you need to give a new version that's it
i mean there are examples but they're
hit right there inside those bullet
points so oh so should i just open
everything
yeah probably
okay
so what are we now i'm going to scroll
through the whole thing what are we
basically looking at here
first we have a bunch of lcc things with
expressions
and then we have the redesign of
expression tree
okay now remind me why we're doing this
and is this
okay
give me a little bit more background
here
right so there are various
um
differences between how
you know sort of
functions that operate on
expressions and
their their tree counterparts differ
which
may or may not be correct uh
so this is to do with head handling or
to do with with part counting or what
well they're
it uh
you know it's
uh showing i mean
with respect to
i mean all sorts of things i i don't
think i can narrow it down
you know
four points
um
and
um
the
um right which i guess is not
necessarily an independent question from
the tree redesign
uh
expression tree redesign but
so
you know right so here's sort of you
know what one
sort of big difference for example
um
right one might expect
if you give it a span rather than
getting
i mean i know maybe this doesn't make
any sense but
but it's sort of weird that
uh
you know
right extract if you give it a span it
preserves the head right if you give it
two separate positions two and three
you'll get a list two and three but if
you give it
um a span
then you preserve the head
do three levels of list
and just do two comma three instead of
in separate lists
with three levels of list
what oh three what what do you mean yes
three levels of lists
yes
like this
right so the heck is that that is the
same as what you would get if you did
list of
two of the span
right that is a single position spec
which is
a a list
two comma three and therefore behaving
the same as part
uh
it's giving you one part
and the part that extracted is part the
the part
list two three
right so if you do part of f abc
comma
list23 that's what you get
but okay so the issue is
what could this is there a way to get it
to include the f here
so let me try to rephrase so so the
in the extract language we have lists
that represent
position so it's like wrapping trapping
levels and lists that represent
multiplicity
and extract is treating them differently
in three extract currently we are
treating them equally always returning
lists
and so it is point is that one of them
should return another three head and i
think in this case i agree
i agree we should change that interest
right if you scroll down a little bit
there's a proposal of what that would
look like
and i think i agree with it
street extract can preserve the data
i'm totally confused by this so
so so in a sense we are returning lists
of children itai is saying in that case
also return a tree that contains
the
the common ancestor
the command exactly
so what identities are supposed to be
true
is there an identity that says
you can trify an expression do this and
then come back again
if we made this change then yeah if you
did extract of an expression and then
convert those expressions to trees you'd
get the same result as converting the
expression to okay so the identity that
we have is
um extract
of
yes of expert comma spec
um
expression tree across that
that's equal to
tree extract
of x become a spec is that right
it's not uh it's not if we make this
change
right it's wrapping
extra the the on the left hand side oh
expression you the first argument of
tree expression needs to be expression
tree of expert
yeah
right so
let's start over expression tree at
uh
at extract of expert comma spec
okay
should equal
tree extract
of expression
tree at exper
comma spec
yes that is true for that would be true
for a single position if we preserve the
data
what about for multiple positions
there would be map
okay fine
okay
i mean on the face of it seems right to
me to do this
to make that identity be true
i agree
okay onward tree map at
so the issue here is that
um
tree map
applies the function to the data
so we wanted to follow that for tree map
at
but that causes there to be some
confusion
if you have a position that ends in zero
are you referring to the position
like are you referring to the data at
this position or are you referring to a
position that itself
is a position within the data
wait a minute usually the act
simply refers to a tree location you
can't sort of breach the expression
boundary and start referring to subparts
of the expression right so so it's like
map
applies the function to the whole sub
expression but tree map only applies the
function to the data at that position
and tree map follows that same precedent
from tree map
but the problem is that the data of a
sub tree is technically a different
position from
the sub tree at that position
my god okay all right let's try this
again all right so what you're saying is
the
usually tree map at
says go apply this function f
particular location
normally that location but it's applying
the function f to the data at that
location exactly it applies it to the
data at that position whereas mapat
applies it to the sub expression at that
position
i understand but if if what was
specified at that position was in fact a
sub tree
what then happens
if you hadn't gone all the way down to
the bottom of the tree
and you said tree map at a partial
location just applies to the data at
that position without affecting the
children
oh i see so it only ever applies to data
yes
okay so what's the question
so then the the issue with that is
because it applies to the data that's
implicitly adding a zero to the end of
every position spec
like so we say tree map out of position
one
okay so your point is a tree one zero
right a tree doesn't have the same part
numbering as the expression underneath
the tree
yeah the data is position zero
so if you have a position and then you
say zero that moves into the data and
then i understand i understand but but
that's because
the tree expression the the actual
expression tree of tree of tree of tree
of tree whatever
right is close to the part numbering
of its part numbering is close to the
part numbering okay i'm sorry the
logical part numbering of the tree
is close to the literal structural part
numbering of the underlying expression
but it isn't exactly the same right so
position zero is the first argument of
tree and then positive positions are the
corresponding positions in the list of
children
right
right and right so i mean and i think
this this really comes to a head if you
look at the third input so you'll notice
the first input
the first two inputs where i start with
one and then one zero i get the same
thing because
one the first one it's not applying it
to the tree it's applying it to the data
and one zero is explicitly the data but
then we do this additional i know i
understand
okay i don't think the the the
i think there should be a a rat wall so
to speak to prevent the rodent burrowing
into the head
i mean into the data of the tree in
other words i think tree map at
should just have
specifications of tree elements
and nothing more and it doesn't even
need
you know that zero there is irrelevant
so in so positions ending in zero would
just be prohibited
i think so i think that and i think the
idea of a mixed tree map out and map at
is crazy i think if you want the thing
to go into the head into the data
and then
map at a certain position in the data
say tree map map at whatever
but
the main utility of this is to modify
the data
of the trees
right so by doing that we would be
forcing
everybody to do those combinations of
functions
wait a second that's assuming that the
function they're applying is map at and
not you know just f
to some right yes i mean i i think that
the um
um
perhaps i misunderstood so i think the
important point here is that the
function is still mapped on the data
where it can borrow inside
yeah perhaps we wouldn't do it i don't
think we should borrow inside i think it
should be a um you know
fully
rat wall so to speak
no rodent burrows further down than the
actual
tree itself i think that makes sense for
treemapbat uh my question is treextract
does support extracting out of the data
but i think that's probably less
problematic if we keep that behavior
think of the weird
yeah i mean i i i also and i think
there's a section on tree extract and
that that one is weird but it's less i
agree it's less problematic i still
think it's very weird i think that it
might be safer to just disallow it right
now and if we find we keep on needing it
let's let's think about that later
so i'll just pull out support for
position zero in these functions
yes don't allow them to go in
don't allow them to burrow into the data
yep
i mean it's very weird if you have zeros
here and then the zeros mean a different
thing they mean heads inside the data
it's just gonna get really weird really
quickly i mean this is a tree extract
because it is doing tree-like extraction
rather than doing expression-like
extraction
yep
okay
deleting your head
deleting your head is weird
right so this is something that's not
yet implemented and
[Music]
um or is that something that now
evaluates well so
right currently position zero is only
supported in any form in
tree extract and tree map at we don't
support it in tree delete and the
question is do we want to support
position zero and if so what should it
do
you mean it blows away the data
yes i think it is
there's two two choices it could blow
away the data or it could do what delete
does
and delete the actual node there
we're talking tree delete here
yes yes
right so what's in the comment is the
input and
the the the thing that's actually
evaluating is the faked output
okay
right so in one case it just makes the
data disappear leaving an empty node and
in the other case
it blows away the node and all this
children become children of that node's
parent which is what
delete does on expressions
and i would favor the latter
the blowing away the thing and making
everything the
the direct descendants of its encloser
what happens if it has no encloser
maybe in that case it just
replaces it with null
kind of right right so just like we just
like we special case
the uh the
right when you there's a special case
for or
when you delete the the head of the
whole expression and it replaces it with
sequence
so we have we'll have to special case
that and it'll be you know a node with
no data in it
which i guess that we use null for that
i have to say once again that these
things seem to me like they're sort of
semi-bugs
by the time you get to
you know deleting the head of the whole
the top of the whole tree
i do feel like deleting the head of sub
sub trees is a useful operation that we
don't have another way to do
wait a minute so tell me again what it's
going to do so tree delete
of
a particular tree location
will blow away that tree location
and reroute its
no so treatably of a regular position
will get rid of that node and all of its
children
but if you if the position ends in zero
then it would just get rid of that node
and its children would become children
of its parent
oh that's really weird
which we don't have another way to do
right it's like tree surgery
right but that's also right i mean
that's also analogy right that's
completely analogous to what expressions
do right
if i have f of x of one of two of three
and i blow away position one i i blow
away
that whole x of one of two of three i
don't just blow away the x
but if i
blow away the the head of at position
zero then i i'm
left behind with that nested argument
i think we have a meta question here
which is probably the the idea of of of
the whole discussion here is that
expressions have been a main
model for trees
but perhaps they shouldn't be a
completely
um kind of compulsory model yes i think
they should not be
exactly if we find something more useful
to do in some case perhaps we just do
that other thing rather to be
forced to follow expressions
yeah i agree
well do you have a suggestion for what's
the more useful thing
i would remove the data not the node
well my view is that removing the node
is more useful because we don't have a
way to remove the node i think we have
should have another function that
removes the node
i think having it having the node
removed by putting a zero there is just
freaking weird
i mean i almost think like
okay so tree delete normally
deletes subtrees that is its normal life
yep
this is
which is what delete also does normally
yep
so i mean
tree delete node are we calling them
nodes right we we have functions that
call them nodes is that true or not
tree element or node
what what do we have that's no i mean
that we have we're not using the word
node in the name of any functions okay
the one tree delete along every element
in the name of functions like tree
element style
to me tree delete element makes more
sense
where we just say we give the you know
the the location of an element and
kaboom it disappears
to element delete i think we have three
elements in multiple places okay fine
tree element delete
delete can even remove the whole
expression
you can do delete x comma double empty
list
and it
self removes itself
it's like our previous discussion what
does it no no you need to set another
empty list exactly
right you need a list of
empty positions
not a single empty
not no position right that's no position
specifications if you double list it's a
list containing one
empty specification oh my gosh
three delete does this as well and and i
think it's right that it does it does
what
if you do tree delete and have a double
empty list you get sequence
but here it's because you are removing
the whole tree yes
no no no separate from replacing the
head with sequence right
okay
right right empty list is the position
corresponding to the whole expression so
you've just said delete the whole
expression so tree delete of double
empty list is delete the whole tree
there can't be much left behind
yeah i get it i get it
um
so it sounds like we're saying
also don't allow position zero in tree
delete and have a separate tree element
delete that deals with that case
i'm sorry sorry i spaced for a second
could you say that again
sounds like we're saying tree delete
also should not support position zero at
all that's correct you have a separate
function tree element delete
right so tree delete delete subtrees
and it should say that and tree element
delete
deletes
elements of trees
and re and re-plums the tree
reconnects the tree
does that make sense
it's a it's a bypass operation we indeed
right
it's tree surgery it's some kind of
bypassing of pieces of
i hate to even imagine
what's that yes right
nodes
right
one day no doubt there'll be a way to do
that for
bronchial
whatever's um
anyway
uh okay so i think that's that one okay
tree insert
no it really shouldn't do this it really
really should not it should not breach
the the um you know the tree
leaf boundary
the tree data boundary
okay
so is there any more to discuss about
tree insert
i don't think so
okay expression tree are we on to this
yep
so the key thing from last discussion
was we identified
that the two shapes that we care about
our heads goes to true and heads goes to
false
and then all of the other questions are
about what do we use as the data so i
have four base cases
and then two options that affect all of
those cases
two and also heads okay so hold on hold
on the thing that i'm most keen on for
my practical uses of trees is i want to
display the tree without a lot of
greenery
do i now have a way to do that
that isn't crazy
so
we're taking two approaches one is if
you have
you want to specify a different
structure that has what you want
specifically in it and then the other
one is
having options that allow you to easily
say i want like don't show me
any internode labels or look color i
want to take this and i want to make it
into the analog
of um
i mean i want to make it display more or
less like that
but in in the tree format as well okay
so
i i think that is a separate discussion
that we have
we've already discussed it and it's
straightened out we're gonna have tree
element function tree elements style
function
tree element shape all of those options
and then you'll be able to do this
easily okay okay
but this is the question of how do you
actually make that initial tree and
specify all the different
combinations of that
i see
from
from an expression
taking apart an expression and making a
tree from it yep right and you know just
just to be completely clear about our
previous discussion
those identities only hold for certain
mappings right you can have
you know some of these ways of forming
trees from expressions will not preserve
the identities because you can't
simultaneously
satisfy the identity of multiple exactly
mappings
there is no centralizer to to the group
of mappings
from expressions to trees
wait a minute
sorry
say that again what what can you not say
i got distracted again i apologize what
can you not satisfy we wrote an identity
above with tree extract and
it's just not it's only going to hold
depending on what expression structure
you use because otherwise i see i see i
got it yep i get it i understand
okay so
the question here is
what is the expression we're doing this
word
it's the expression
yeah
okay
and so the top row is with heads goes to
false the second rows of heads goes to
true
so
okay so what we're saying is
the data at every step contains
heads
sub-expressions
or only i think why isn't that leaves
it's the atoms of the expression
just like the heads and the
sub-expressions of the expression i feel
like leaves is referring to the tree
the heads of the
oh i see i see i just saying
yes i see what you're saying
the names are kind of like
pour all of the data from the whole tree
into a bucket what's the word that
describes all of it
like the first tree i know i know i know
but one question is presumably there's a
level spec for expression tree
is there a level spec for expression
tree
right now there isn't are you saying
only go down i mean like what tree form
has like an in
like a max level yes
yeah we could have a max level i think
it should because i think that that um
not a not a full level specification but
like a maximum level of tree to build
correct
yeah the other way around so it's like
it's a tree that's or or yes
right
it's how deep you go in the expression
and treeing it out so you're not going
down i mean i can also imagine it being
useful to have excluded forms
yes we will
okay that i was thinking about that for
the binary decision tree like you say
excluded forms is not
and then you get the right expression
tree
okay
right otherwise yeah i mean so for
example somehow i've been building
uh we've got
x-blank as a leaf effectively
and if you don't exclude pattern you're
you know toasted
is there a null version is there another
version of hats goes to true
yeah i just didn't show it
okay
and all this does is to zero out the
data in every place
this shows the same structure
this shows the tree of the expression
but we're zeroing out all of the data
yep
okay
well this seems okay i'm okay so far
and the proposal is we'd have
options tied to specific two specific
structures instead of to expression tree
since expression tree is going to have
lots of different structures
what do you mean by that
so here i'm specifying heads goes to
true in a list
with the sub expressions
what
because the second argument could be xml
and that's going to have different
options
than expressions
so what i don't think it should be in a
sub list why is it in a sub that's
really absolutely not an option to
expression tree it's an option for the
structure
yeah but we do that in import for
example
we have you know options it's sort of a
poly-optional
function
to see what i mean
depending on whether you're you know
whether whether you're a gif or whether
you're a
i don't know an audio file or something
you have different options for import
i think it's okay
to do that
directly to import to expression tree
yes
it would be a matter of supporting them
doesn't hold sub expressions also
actually apply to everything
right why is this specific to
sub-expressions
what do you mean
this next item here
does it apply to atoms or heads as well
yeah it's an option for all of those
structures okay so then blow away the
the braces
but not for xml
is what i know but it's okay so we just
ignore it in that case
yes so the important point here is that
we can support that but then it's
documentation that
that becomes more complicated in for
example
import has all these options but if you
do options of import you you get nothing
right but i i right because import has
those special
we may end up wanting documentation
pages dedicated to specific structures
that's what i think of having expression
free be super complicated yes that's
what i think too and i think by the time
you get xml so what are you imagining
that the xml import looks like
an xml expression
you'll see you're going to say
expressiontree of the xml object
comma string xml
fine although you probably shouldn't
need the string xml
what is it going to do by default in one
argument formed with an ordinary
expression
what it currently does which is what
convert everything fully to a tree
which is the case of atoms or the case
of what
which case here is the automatic case
its heads with heads goes to false and
with recursive expression tree goes to
true
i have it there okay
so i think that it should be automatic
by default and i think it should depend
on the first argument and i think we
should try and do some sensible things
that possibly aren't that
so have it
like detect the
which structure to use i think so and i
think for example if what you have in
the first the first element there
is a whole collection i mean i would
even say if it's a whole collection
nested lists and then below the list so
random other things
i would say that there's an argument
that it should trify down to the end of
the lists and not beyond by default
because that's what's going to be useful
and it's all the rather hard disposable
arrays
yeah well and might might be you had an
array and you wanted to actually look at
the expression structure you'd have to
so then that would be you'd
say something other than automatic
yes but i think there's an argument that
expression tree should have a
specification that says go down to the
bottom of the lists
it's different from your
things yeah no i think we should have a
specific structure that's just called
list or something like that
yeah i agree with you and another one
called the raise you know which is
the full depth array
okay so let's look at this so i i don't
think these should be string options i
think we should figure out how to make
these non-string options
okay
so what does hold sub-expressions do
so
it wraps things in hold form at like the
the last step
where it needs to wrap them in hold form
to prevent evaluation
you mean inside the data yes
right because
which is not necessarily just wrapping
the data in hold form like if you have
recursive expression tree goes to true
the whole forms are going to be deeper
inside which is why i have this as an
option
oh boy
okay well i think i understand hold
sub-expressions but
i feel like that's an option which is
similar to options of other functions
and i'm trying to understand how to
unify it with that
why
why is it not just wrapping the data in
hold form
so for example in that recursive
expression tree the payload will still
be a tree it won't be a hold form of a
tree
oh okay
which is necessary in order for part
extraction and all that to still work
okay
but i'm i'm asking again i think there
are other functions which have this
property that it is they are
sort of recursively holding things
sub-expression holding in other words
for example
doesn't extract have a third argument
that is what it does
you know hold for example there's a
third argument of extract well the
difference is that
you know
extract
uh right i mean
extract it you know right since it's
done in c code extracts without
evaluating and then it can choose to
wrap each result in
the optional third argument so you can
prevent it from evaluating when it's
returned to you
right and level has an optional argument
that wraps all of the results instead of
wrapping each one individually
okay which is analogous to what you want
expression tree to do
is that correct
i think neither is
it's more like
what extract does but with extract
you're saying where are the things you
want to extract
and where are you wrapping the whole
form depends on which structure you're
using whether you're using heads or
sub-expressions or
okay
all right let me understand recursive
expression tree
what does that do
so normally heads would be
like the actual sub-expression and
recursive expression tree converts
anything other than a tree converts it
to a tree using the same options
recursively
you think you mean
in
well
right any compound head is converted to
a tree rather than being stored
as
a compound if the head is a compound
expression yes
if the head is a compound expression
then you apply expression tree to it
why isn't that heads goes to all
heads is specifying
which sub-expressions have a
corresponding tree
and this is controlling
the data
instead i understand but if heads is
false
then you're not going in
you can have this option for both heads
goes to true and for heads goes to false
it's independent
i don't understand what what if if heads
is false it will never go into the head
no so how does it look
then
heads do not become sub trees
compared to the trees above
yeah in both cases you have f of a b so
young wants to convert those
those into trees
you would still go into the head it's
just it doesn't become a sub tree
in in which case would you go into that
so
right
remind us the top row is heads heads
goes to true our heads goes to false
the top rows heads goes to false
right so you're right you have f of a b
that's the compound head and you just
see its children
and
heads goes to true
right that f is repeated as a head
to
the uh
um
right you see in the second row the
first item
there's
one of the children corresponds to the
head
second row first item
this one here
right so then
it has a child that corresponds to the
head
of f a b
of f of a b of g of one two x
what
okay
in this case the whole expression right
of g of one two x
right the root right yeah so in the
middle item you see the whole expression
it's f of a b of g of one
yeah right so in the leftmost tree the
first one is the head of the overall
expression then you go down one and
rather than just seeing the children of
the head you see f repeated
as
a head
and then you have
um
right why do you repeat the head
yeah yeah why do you you can go from
heads goes to true to heads goes to
false by just deleting the first child
of every sub tree
that's the only difference between
i would have thought that heads goes to
true
would simply ask the question do you go
inside the head period
so my reading of this is that sub
expressions is the easy case to
understand and then to preserve the same
structure
as a tree
but just changing the data
heads does that which is a bit of
arbitrary string heads refers to the
the different data
the symbol heads is controlling the
structure of the tree
right yeah so maybe you should compare
the second item of the two rows right
in one case you just have
um
right you don't see f
of a b anywhere
but in one case right so if heads goes
to false i wouldn't expect to see the f
of a b
right that's heads goes to true
no it goes to false the second row is
heads goes to true
yes where it says heads goes to true and
hurts goes to fall that's a bit
confusing because that section is only
heads goes to true hatch goes to false
is the previous section
yes
exactly
okay that's exactly what i would expect
capital heads this heads goes to true if
heads goes to false it doesn't go into
the head
right
okay now the recursive expression tree
refers to the data
so does not care whether you have the
full sub expression or the head
it just converts the data to an
expression tree
you're saying it converts the data
inside the tree
yes
is that useful
it's the default
for current expression tree and the
reason i chose that is so that
it satisfies the identity about position
specs that we said earlier to where the
position specs of the expression tree
correspond one for one with the position
specs in the expression
but that's breaking the rat wall
isn't it
that's allowing that that position spec
when you have a sub tree when the data
is itself a tree
you have to break through the the rodent
wall
don't you to get into it's like i've
replaced every compound expression with
a tree
yes i understand
but
but to be able to use tree extract to go
down into those you know to be able to
use a single tree extract to go through
the upper level of the tree
then you hit the rodent wall
then you go into the then you go into
the data area
you know the data enclave there
and start
burrowing into the data
right
just like an expression the head is
either atomic or a compound expression
here the head will either be
or here the data will either be an
atomic
expression or it will be a tree i
understand but what i'm saying is tree
extract shouldn't allow if tree extract
if there are three levels to the outer
tree
then you hit the rodent wall
then you go into the data
i claim that a single tree extract
should not be able to have indices that
refer to both of those things
does that make sense
basically like what we were saying
earlier like don't support position zero
in anything
yeah that's what i'm saying don't go
into the don't let you get in don't let
you jump
from tree
into
i mean it's kind of like like um there
are creatures that live on the outside
of the tree and then there's kind of
like the maggot whatever they are the
the whatever the heck those things are
that the burrow into trees
i don't think we should i think that the
inner life inside the tree
is a different thing from the stuff
that's hanging in the canopy outside the
tree
this is a bit of fun but this function
also isn't doing burrowing it's just
converting an expression into a tree
and this is i know that i just don't
think it should do it with i i think
that if you want
we have had the opposite discussion when
we were considering operator forms and
we were trying to use street form on
operating forms and it never did the
right thing
it never did the right thing because it
was unable to enter the heads and
representatives
heads arrow true
can go and headify to its uh you know
heart's content
heads is controlling what children there
are recursive expression tree is
controlling whether the heads get turned
into trees
inside the data
i mean they are two logically
independent options because really
okay so hold on one is whether it goes
into the heads
i'm i'm sorry i'm really not getting it
is it the case that this breaking
is whether it goes into the heads
recursive expression tree is whether the
data is converted to a tree well the
data where is converted to everywhere
data of every node
so in other words what's the reason that
expression tree would not have converted
things maybe it's level spec you know if
you say go only to level two then things
below level two are non it's like
questions look at heads look at the very
first one you say heads and the root
node contain contains an f of a b
yes
that's the case i'm talking about
case for what where it isn't converted
yeah right it didn't do that
but i i want you the the case i'm
mentioning where you only go down to
level two then every lower level
is also not converted but if you had
your recursive expression tree thing i
see then even those lower levels you
thought were not converted will actually
get converted
maybe it only applies to inner nodes
then
but even by inner nodes not leaves
how can an inner node of expression tree
not be
treed out unless it's either hitting the
depth limit
or it's ahead
i don't get it
i don't get how it can how it can ever
fail to treatify
other than by being ahead
otherwise it's a normal
okay so then what i'm claiming is that
the cases are the last time you said you
wanted an option so that you could do
the same thing for sub expressions as
well
which is why currently
we just have a separate standalone
structure called head trees because
that's the interesting case
but you could imagine doing this for
sub-expressions and then you would be
turning every
sub-expression into a tree not just the
heads
what is head trees where what what's
that entries is the current
like
in 12 30
or
name for what
default expression structure
oh i see
and it effectively has recursive
expression tree goes to true
last time we discussed this
you mentioned
why does that only happen for heads and
maybe that's this discussion we're
having now
but it could just be done for
sub-expressions
how could ever
at every node
of the full below it
sub-expression
okay i'm finally understanding okay so
in the case of sub-expressions
where you have a big globulous
expression at every node there's the
question of is that expression
then rendered as a tree in the node
yep
i see
kind of trees all the way down or not
exactly
go until there are no compound
expressions left
so this is something that is clearly
more useful for heads goes to false
which is the the the situation
implicitly in tree form which is what
where this discussion started
yep
this will become less useful in health
goes to true because as you said
there is already the heads
represented as a child
okay
all right we got these two
options um
[Music]
really what this is
this recursive thingy
is tree elements become trees
is that a first statement
in some sense yeah like the data of tree
elements
trees all the way down
um
no
uh
you can't have expression tree with an
option called recursive expression tree
it has a it's a self-referential
function but it has its own option
it's like
it's
it's what it's a fractal tree yes yes
yes right
oh gosh
okay
so a tree element
what this is saying is convert tree
elements
to trees
convert the data of tree elements to
trees
or alternatively
data exp it's really data expressions
expressions that appear in data will
they become trees
that's what we're answering right
expressions that appear within
expressions as data what happens to them
well there's a compound expression of
things with semicolons
no it's
we can't use the word compound
expression
because the compound expression is a
function that is the the the expression
is the name of a function but also the
terminology for non-atomic expressions
is compound expression
i thought it was normal expressions
but i admit normal expressions isn't
beautiful why do we say compound
expressions
do we use that terminology
i mean we use it informally i know but i
thought we were avoiding that because
compound expression was named as the as
the you know
as the sequencing thing okay in any case
um i know what you mean
right
uh
okay so the issue is does every
sub-expression turn into a tree
well i mean look i can imagine something
called sub-expression trees
i hate that it's inside a function
called expression tree and then we're
saying sub-expression trees
um
what is the name of the thing is it tree
element data or it's tree data right
yep
the data has three or three data has
three goes to false or true
data trees goes to true
obscure
tree data tree now tree data
convert tree data to trees
i understand the concept now finally
uh
by the way does it go down and just like
that
of the heads option
like we don't have the corresponding
thing for tree like go into the data
yeah
does it do it recursively i mean that is
if it's if it's a tree within a tree
within a tree what does it do
keeps going
really
i mean it's not obvious that that's the
right thing to do
if we have
oh i see what you're saying
you're saying
so i only have that as the default for
the
correspondence with position specs
but if we're getting rid of position
zero for now yeah that's not a good
argument
for it being the default
it's really render data as trees
it's something like that
yeah
i like that
i don't like the word render though
rinder's misleading it makes me think
that it's only formatting that way
trees for tree data
sounds like some kind of uh
environmental campaign
um
but it's a rendering thing right so it
would be more like render trees data as3
yes
that's right
except for the word render
which we don't tend to use
yes
render in the sense of transform
how about something like use trees for
tree data
but i'm not confused so is this deciding
whether to insert three three three
symbols
yes
if you have that option this will
actually change the data to be a tree
instead
so then it's more like
use trees for
for non-atomic heads
well no because for the data inside a
tree
what it's going to be is it's going to
be a tree
this specifically applies to inner nodes
that have compound expressions as their
data
right but in the end the structure will
be a tree whose payload is a tree
yes but it's children with a payload as
a tree
but this is the option that is deciding
whether that payload is going to be a
tree or not that's correct
hence
saying for tree data
[Music]
well i mean there's another possibility
which is tree data representation
goes to
trees
expression
it's another possibility
do we just want to have head trees
like we do now
just as a base structure and not have it
be an option
it's irrelevant to atoms and for null
and it's not very interesting for sub
expressions
why i had trees
no that seems like the wrong thing i
don't because those other ones affect
only
i don't know
i don't know i mean my favorite so far
has used trees for tree data
represent tree data with trees
tree data as trees
tree data as trees doesn't seem
absolutely terrible
yeah i like that too
okay
so hold sub-expressions will be
hold tree data arrow true or false is
that true
say that again sorry it's like hold
atoms
what's hold atoms where's their old
atoms
no it like i'm suggesting that as a name
like
the whole forms get wrapped tightly
around the atomic expressions not around
the data
what do you mean around the atomic
expressions atomic expressions are then
the data they're in the data part of the
tree aren't they i'm saying if if you
have a tree
as the data
you don't wrap the tree and hold form
you go into that tree itself okay so
that's the interaction between
tree data as trees and the held
sub-expressions business yes
right but if you have a normal compound
expression as theta i hope you just
yeah
so if you have recursive expression tree
goes to false then it's just wrapping
all of the data in hold form
before
recursive expression tree goes to true
or tree data as trees goes to true
then it keeps going into the trees
until it finds atomic expressions and
wraps those in hold form
so it's really hold tree data arrow true
or false
is it not
good
are you sure that there isn't i mean
i mean maybe i think it should be
wrapped around a whole tree
look i think it should be something like
tree data wrapper tree data
what's the right word for rapper
[Music]
and then you could say hold or identity
i think it's more general because that
way we can have hold form hold hold
complete whatever else you want
okay
and this would still interact
the way i'm saying like driving drilling
into the trees
i think so
is there a reason why this couldn't be
an optional third argument
that's what i would think it would
naturally be based on extract and so on
well i think the third argument most
likely will be the max level
oh
yeah and
i i still think this makes sense as an
option because it's not for every kind
of structure
okay but but is there a precedent for
something that is called a wrapper here
we've we've got that i think in lots of
places we've got things that wrap
results and we've got a name for this
and i'm trying to think what it is
i think we normally call it function
right oh yes yes that's right tree data
function that will be the natural thing
to call it
it's just a function to apply to tree
data which actually
i think there could be all kinds of
useful functions to apply
to process the tree data when you
extract it
so the struct what i'm calling the
structures like the string structures
are the function to apply
to get a tree and we're talking about
the function to apply to the data
afterwards
that's correct
actually i'm confused
why tree data as trees isn't simply tree
data function arrow
and then a tree making function and then
why isn't this that arrow expression
tree
it's like expression tree with the same
options as the outer expression tree
okay that's the difference
well and also right it's oh that's only
applied to
normal expressions not to atoms
okay fine
fine but it's very similar to tree data
function as expression tree arguing
again for a tree data function because i
think it's a general useful thing right
i mean we could theoretically have like
a special name string right just like
the color data function can be a named
string for yes that's a good point we
could have a special string that
represents or maybe automatic
could be
i like that idea the other thing is that
as independent options you can specify
hold along with expression tree
if we just had a named like string
expression tree
is that useful to do that through the
names along with it
i'm saying how do you do a recursive
expression tree and i know but is that
useful because i mean
where are you holding it you're holding
the atoms
regardless of if you specify a rapper
expression tree is already careful about
not letting the expression evaluate
so it's purely a question of once you've
stored the thing in the tree
what do you wrap it in
and that's why it's only needed for the
atoms
well
i think you should have a little think
about whether tree data whether with
several strings including you know held
atoms or something as a string or some
such other thing we could avoid the tree
data as trees
and just have a tree data function
because i think i think that's clearer i
think people will understand the tree
data function does something to the tree
data as it inserts it you know the
description is this is a function to
apply to tree data when it is inserted
in the tree yep
and you know one of the things you can
do is turn it into an and you know one
of the special cases is you can turn it
into a subtree
tree data function arrow subtree or
something
okay i think we nailed it
so the only two options would be heads
and tree data function that's what i
think i think it's nice
yep i i think i think we've covered
everything and those are good
functioning and we would have four these
four structures and not have like
expression as a structure
and these are some cases
right i could imagine we could have
additional structures yeah structures i
think so too i think i think they could
actually these are basically free data
function
are they equivalent to a tree data
function
i think so like tree data function goes
to heads
or tree data function goes to identity
tree data function goes to null but then
how do you combine them
no i mean this is not a tree data
function
have a think about it simple but but i
also recommend for that second argument
that we have things like uh you know
lists and arrays and so on absolutely
different ways to you know like an
import i mean this is basically an
importer
this is importing from expressions to
trees
right we were already planning those for
associations etc and and i agree this is
not the same thing
these structures select what the data is
not what you wrap the data with
correct
yes
i think we got it
so
good stuff all right i'm going to
disappear here
bye